so I have a real interest in the nature
of the orgasm and I'm not just talking
about the ecstatic expect you lations
the temporary moment of bliss beyond
measure when we lose ourselves and find
ourselves right there's a absolution a
disintegration and a reintegration
there's apathy OSIS when we blow our
load I get it it's magnificent it's
mechanical it can be deconstructed it
can be explained but what I'm interested
in is what it tells us about
consciousness and self-awareness right
when we witness that ecstatic
disintegration when we finally lose
ourselves and something happens right
most people are familiar with how good
it feels to lose ourselves in an orgasm
very few people spend time talking about
what just happened let's talk about the
metaphysics of it let's talk about the
supernatural charge of an orgasm I mean
is there anything that feels as good is
there anything more addicting is there
anything more desirable than to lose
ourselves I think about this all the
time I was you know since the since the
time that I lost my virginity I wanted
to philosophize about what had just
transpired I wanted to understand where
I went where we went there's an element
of intersubjectivity there's an element
of sexually enabled telepathy there's an
element of feeling
and it connected to your lover in ways
you never knew were possible there's a
kind of mind and body smearing there's a
loss of self there's a loss of identity
there's a loss of evil but awareness
persists right you drowned in ecstasy
but you don't panic right you die but
without fear there's a reason that
orgasm is called the little death and
maybe we can take some comfort in
knowing that this kind of surrender that
this little death results not in our
non-being but rather in our rebirth
maybe there's something to be learned
from them maybe there's something to be
taken from that maybe we shouldn't fear
the things we fear maybe we should hold
on so tightly to ourselves but rather be
willing to surrender
[Music]